esta es la escena con la que se despertó
pascal boas el miércoles cuando salió a
buscar su coche por la mañana
parecía una pesadilla o una película es
realmente mi coche
el diputado galo del partido la
repubblica en marcha de manuel macrón
también se encontró con amenazas
etiquetadas en la pared de su casa con
el mensaje vota no una probable
referencia al pase vacunal que se está
tramitando en la asamblea francesa
en democracia se puede estar en
desacuerdo pero hay otras formas de
expresarse en unos 5 millones de
franceses elegibles a la vacuna aún no
han recibido ni una sola dosis mientras
que el gobierno planea convertir la
tarjeta sanitaria de francia en una
tarjeta de vacunación que permitiría
sólo a los totalmente vacunados tener
acceso a sitios públicos un número
creciente de diputados en particular del
partido la república en marcha han
recibido amenazas o correos de odio de
un sector radical antivacunas voy a leer
un mensaje que he recibido hoy si no
votas no al proyecto de ley jan se
recordará la asamblea nacional como un
gigantesco año de sangre para este tipo
de intimidación no tiene cabida en
nuestra república la presidenta del
grupo de la república en marcha en la
asamblea nacional aurore verge también
recibió amenazas y ha pedido penas
severas acordes con la gravedad de las
intimidaciones mientras tanto la
respuesta del gobierno fue proporcionar
más seguridad a los diputados mientras
se examinan el proyecto de ley sobre el
pase de vacunas con patrullas policiales
en el exterior de sus despachos así como
en sus domicilios